we wanted to make this pirates of the
carribean I'm really special and really
fresh so we got two new directors yoke
investment who are Academy nominated
filmmakers reinvigorate the franchise
with something we've never seen before
there are new characters are going to
bring a new flavor and a different
dimension to one of the most powerful
franchises of all time when we heard
they were planning on making another
pirate we taped it we wanted to feel
like the right be found on scary and
emotional and that means huge action
pieces
[Music]
we have powerful extras a huge build and
epic shots with fantastic location
this film is exciting there's something
huge happening every day so it has an
energy in a force mind but I've never
really experienced before
not only is it huge in cockpit we're
dealing with iconic characters and like
only ships an element I felt there was
something the magic walking on to up
that scene the craftsmanship in the
details it's very easy to lose yourself
and to feel like you are in another
world
still men tell no tales pirates had
infected disease for generations so I
filed to eliminate them all
that's bottle who cursed me I will have
my revenge
you sure your V Jack's phone
furs upon a great planet does not
require such intricate
spiral Kareena is the only one who can
help
I'm not looking for trouble horrible
magazine
I'm a woman of science I choose not to
believe in ghosts
you know see what's behind us
Oh monkey
I'm a pirate this stupid and this bill
contains things that may be too intense
for younger viewers
you